hi everyone I'm ujja from Stanford
University today it is my great honor to
present you the complexity of infinite
Verizon General some stochastic games
the talk is based on joint work with
Vidya musukuma and Aaron said for
let's first look at a basic mathematical
model Markov chain
it is composed of three parts States
transition probabilities and Rewards
at every stage there is a transition
probability Vector to the other states
which characterize the transition
this could be either randomized or
deterministed
while we do not have any decisions for
players to make here we can still have
different players for a Markov chain in
the model we can define instant rewards
that each player will receive at each
state where we which we denote by r
this may be completely independent among
players in general this can be defined
for arbitrary many players too
the utility of a player is defined by
collecting all the instant rewards she
receives throughout the process there
are two well-known Notions of utilities
the average reward and discounted reward
they are well defined as long as we fix
some initial distribution over the
states
given an initial distribution the notion
of average reward computes the long-term
average of instant rewards that the
player receives throughout the process
as an example we show here how to
compute the average reward for the first
player
on the other hand the discount reward
computes the infinite sum of discounted
rewards where we discount more for steps
further in the future
here we give an example to compute the
discounted reward utility for the first
player
now we have gone over the basics of
Markov chain how is that related to our
topic today
actually the most General game model I'm
going to talk about is simultaneous
stochastic games
it is basically a generalization of
Markov chain for multiplayers by
incorporating the decision-making
process into it
besides the three basic components for
Markov chain it also has actions defined
for players
consider again our toy example with two
players
we now give these two players control on
the two states
this means that they respectively have
some action they can choose to take from
at each state and their joint actions
decide the transition probability vector
and also their instant Rewards
we got the strategy as the collection of
all players actions for each state
note that we not only allow
deterministic or pure strategies but
also allow randomized or mixed strategy
for each player
for a fixed strategy the model still
reduces to a Markov chain and the
utility of players could be measured
similarly as we mentioned
the goal for studying simultaneous
stochastic games is to find strategy
that achieves Nash equilibrium of
utilities
or do so in an approximate sense
these types of games are very prominent
in our daily life for instance in
autonomous driving the future State
depends on both other player other
drivers and your own action
and different drivers may have
completely different goals first this
becomes a natural instance of
simultaneous stochastic games
while the games we introduced previously
are very general and very natural there
are also two important special cases
which are interesting on their own
one class is known as term-based
stochastic games
basically it has the same components the
main difference is now for each state we
assign a controller and only the
controller can pick different actions at
that State
here in our toy example
green player controls the Green State
and gray player controls the gray state
only the controller's action will decide
the transition probability and the resp
reward that each player receives at the
state
here the strategy corresponds to the
collection of controllers action for
each single state which of course can
still be randomized in a mixed strategy
when fixing a strategy this still
reduces to a Markov chain and the
utility can be measured in a similar way
the goal for studying term-based
stochastic games is also to find a
strategy that achieves the Nash
equilibrium or do so in an approximate
sense
these types of games are very popular
for instance in a chess game or board
game the game iterates round by round
among the players and at each round only
one player takes the action
those are natural examples of term-based
stochastic games
putting all these classes together we
start from Markov chain which
characterize transitions on the states
when we want to further incorporate
decision making of more agent in the
games here comes turn-based stochastic
games and simultaneous stochastic games
we make a few assumptions on the model
we study
first we assume State and action spaces
are finite
we focus on learning stationary policy
which does not depend on the timestamp T
third we assume all instant rewards
received are non-negative for all
players
finally we focus on well-conditioned
class of games meaning that the model
parameter one overwhelming schema for
the discounted games and team mix the
mixing time for the average reward games
are both polynomially bounded by the
problem representation size for example
the state size and the action space size
there are a few facts that people
already know about these problems
for simultaneous games people do believe
that it is a hard problem more
concretely they are known to be at least
p-pad hard since the simultaneous
stochastic games with a single state
were reduced to a normal form games
which is known to be pee pad hard
here I'm not going to talk about the
formal definition of ppap complexity
class but basically you can think of it
as equivalent to solving an approximate
natural equilibrium of the two player
General sum games
for turn-based stochastic games people
don't have any idea about how hard this
problem is
there indeed are some facts hinting that
the problem may be easy
for instance we do know that zero sums
are turn-based games is easy
single State turn-based Games as opposed
to the simultaneous counterparts
degenerate to a single state markup
decision process and consequently are
also easy
and Computing non-stationary natural
equilibrium for turn-based stochastic
games are also known to be easy
So based on these known facts our work
give a more complete picture of the
complexity of this class of games
in particular we showed that SSG is not
harder by two player General some normal
form games by formally establishing the
membership of finding an approximate
Dash equilibrium of an ssgs inside the
p-pad complexity class
for turn-based stochastic games we show
they are just as hard as SSG although
being more structured
we proved the p-pad hardness of finding
an approximate Niche for turn-based
stochastic games
we also managed to identify an easy
subclass of turn-based games which have
a nice local reward structure
we proved for such special class of
turn-based games with localized rewards
we can indeed design polynomial time
algorithms using the potential game idea
first of all before diving into our
techniques and how we achieved all these
results I'd like to give a little detour
on the common challenge for studying
these classes of games
the common challenges the utility
function for player I which we denote by
UI as a function of strategy of player I
Pi I and other player strategy Pi minus
I this utility function is not
necessarily linear convex or concave in
the variables
to illustrate this point here is the
visualization of the utility function
for some fixed single player mdp with
five states
when fixing actions on all the other
states and only changing strategy on
state 1 linearly the blue figure shows
how the utility will change and it turns
out to be a non-linear and non-concave
function
when fixing actions on other states and
changing strategy on state 2 linearly
the red figure is non-linear and
non-convex
this suggests that applying the
classical optimization toolkit to these
problems might be tricky and try to
construct hard instance by playing with
the utility function also seems to be
tricky
so to overcome these challenges our core
idea in the study is try to linearize
all these games
the key observation we make is that
games with linear utilities are
relatively much better understood
for instance for two player General some
standard games which we use to define
the p-pad complexity class
they are a classical types of games we
mentioned earlier
that by definition has linear utilities
for each player I their utility is
characterized by a matrix AI when they
each play strategy Pi 1 and Pi 2 the
utility is simply Pi 1 transpose AI pi
2.
actually due to this nice linear
property they are the first ones that
people are able to establish ppad
complexity results for
for turn-based games and stochastic
simultaneous games we try to view them
as a generalization of General some
normal phone games
in fact although the utility functions
they have are non-linear we show they
satisfy a pseudo-linear property
to formally explain what this property
is
let's fix a player index I and the state
s fix all the other player strategy
Pi minus is and consider two different
strategies player I play at the
corresponding State s which we call Pi
is and Pi Prime is
we could Define a strategy function Pi
Theta which linearly interpolates the
strategy induced by pi and the strategy
induced by pi Prime
note when Theta changes from 0 to 1 only
the strategy of player I as state as
will change and all the other policies
will remain unchanged
the pseudo-linear property essentially
says that the slope of the utility
function of player I between any point
Pi Theta and Pi 0 is close to the slope
defined by pi 1 and Pi zero by a
multiplicative factor of row
as an illustration suppose we have the
utility at Pi 0 and Pi 1 as in the
figure
we could connect them by linear function
and we show u i Pi Theta will not have
slope two different compared with the
slope of this linear function
for any Theta between 0 and 1.
this to the linear property actually has
several nice implications
first when the multiplicative Factor rho
equals to 1 this property basically
implies the utility as a linear function
in player I strategy Pi I
so in general it could be viewed as a
generalization of the linearity
second this is actually a stronger
condition than the element-wise
monotonicity
this condition implies according to wise
monotonicity of the utility function
which actually suffices to ensure the
existence of mixed equilibrium for those
kinds of games
so this property also gives that
alternative way to prove the existence
of Nash equilibrium
also under mild extra conditions this
pseudo-linearity suffices to show that
the problem is not harder than General
some normal form games which lie in the
p-pad complexity class
finally together with other structure of
turn-based games this helps us to show
that solving turn-based games are also
as hard as general some normal form
games
this helps us to establish the p-pad
hardness result
however this hardness result is not
immediate consequence of just the
pseudo-linear utilities
to prove that we also need to design
game gadgets to implement arithmetic
circuit Gates
due to the time constraints I'm not
going into the detail of these
constructions which may be a little bit
complicated basically here are how we
Implement all the different arithmetic
Gates by carefully designing instances
of turn-based games and choosing the
right instant reward and transition
probability vectors
I'm very happy to talk more about them
during the in-person meeting
on a high level the pseudo-linear
property gives us a way to view
turn-based games and simultaneous games
has not been too different from General
some normal form games
and consequently they establish their
complexity similarly as people do for
General some normal form games
it is worth mentioning that a concurrent
independent work by Costas Noah and Kai
Ching further established the hardness
result for two-player turn-based games
another interesting part in our paper is
a positive result on efficiently solving
structured turn-based games with
localized Rewards
the way we achieve this result is by
viewing these types of games as variant
of potential games
in Game Theory people have defined
potential games or Markov potential
games where there exists a potential
function Phi such that the difference of
the potential function's value could
basically capture all the differences in
each player's utility assuming the
player that player has changed her
strategy
on the high level we try to relate
turn-based games with this extra
localized reward structure to Market
potential games
the special case of turn-based games we
study are local reward instances
basically we assume each player could
only control at most one state and only
receive a non-negative instant reward at
the state that she controls
for all the other states she doesn't
have control
she will only receive a zero instant
reward
we caught this kind of instance as local
reward turn-based games
under such assumptions of localized
reward by algebra we can write the
utility function as this nice form
for each player I the utility is a
product of a function fi that only
depends on player I strategy times of
function GI that only depends on other
players strategy divided by a general
function h
age depends on all player strategy but
are the same for all players and doesn't
depend on I
under such structural property we can
show the utility ratio between the two
policies can be essentially bounded by
the ratio of some defined potential
function Phi for the five properly
defined here
because of this nice ratio equivalence
property this essentially established
the potential condition we need for
Markov potential games in the
logarithmic space
this log space potential game condition
allow us to show several nice properties
for such games
first we can show there must exist pure
strategy Nash where no player needs to
play a mixed strategy
second this allows us to design
polynomial time algorithm for the
problem
the polynomial time algorithm we
consider is a type of method that
basically just alternate between the
coordinates and prove it converges in
polynomial time
by showing at every sub-optimal point we
are able to make big enough progress in
terms of the potential function
this helps us to show that the
alternating coordinate wise algorithm
indeed is a polynomial time algorithm
and this class of localized reward
turn-based games indeed is a class of
games that can be efficiently solved
so putting all the things together and
in conclusion we show the complexity
picture for multiplayer games about
finding an approximate Nash equilibrium
in either the simultaneous stochastic
games or the turn-based stochastic games
we show Finding approximate Nash in both
these kinds of General games are ppac
complete
we also design new efficient polynomial
time algorithms for solving structured
turn-based games
these kinds of results all come from
relating these games to other classes of
well-studied games
for instance for simultaneous and
turn-based stochastic games in general
we reduce them to show the equivalence
with two-player General some normal form
games which has a linear utility
structure
for turn-based stochastic games with
localized reward we relate them to the
mark of potential games and show that
they satisfy this potential game
condition in the logarithmic space
we hope these ideas of relating
different classes of games could find
further utility for studying broader
classes of multiplayer games too
this is the end of my talk thank you
very much
I'd be happy to take any questions and
discuss more about the details of our
work during the in-person conference
thank you